now let's get reaction to the summit
from Republican Senator Tom cotton of
Arkansas the Iraq war veteran is a
member of the Senate Armed Services
Committee and he joins us from Capitol
Hill senator from the very start you
have been in your own words deeply
skeptical of North Korea's intentions
now that it's over what do you think of
the summit and the agreement that
President Trump and Kim jong-un sign
Chris first thanks for having me on to
discuss this incredible day I think this
was an important first step but we have
to remember it was only a first step I
am skeptical of Kim jong-un's commitment
to denuclearizing North Korea the proof
the pudding will be in the heating in
the months to come I know secretary
Pompeo has already left for South Korea
and then he'll be in China tomorrow now
it's time to negotiate the nitty-gritty
details of verifiably and irreversibly
denuclearizing North Korea as president
Trump himself said it may not work out
but they had to sit down and have this
Agreement face-to-face before we can
move on to the next phase of our
negotiations
in the agreement Kim commits to quote
the complete denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula now we'll have to wait
and see what he does in terms of North
Korea but are you concerned that he is
demanding that on our side that we fold
the nuclear umbrella we have had for
decades protecting South Korea and Japan
[Music]
no Chris I'm not concerned that
president the president would withdraw
that umbrella from any of our allies Kim
Jong GaN is the holds the only nuclear
weapons that are on the Korean Peninsula
and that's one thing that is such a
threat not only to South Korea and Japan
and the American citizens and troops
stationed there but to the United States
you know that Kim jong-un has missiles
that have reached the United States so
part of the long-standing American
policy of nuclear security is that we
have a nuclear arsenal to protect
ourselves and our allies so they don't
feel the need to obtain nuclear weapons
I fear that South Korea and Japan and
Taiwan would want to obtain nuclear
weapons if we weren't working towards
the denuclearization of North Korea
but senator as part of the deal you know
that President Trump announced that he
is going to end
join us military exercises with South
Korea do you think that's a good idea
well Chris the president said that we're
ending that pausing them for the time
being we just had the biggest single
exercise each year foal Eagle occurs in
the spring that probably won't happen
for another nine or ten months until the
spring of 2019 I think we'll have a
pretty good read on whether Kim jong-un
is going to keep his commitments until
then meanwhile secretary mattis has said
he was aware of this decision and he
supports the decision regular everyday
training exercises will occur secretary
Madison wouldn't have supported the
decision if he wasn't confident that our
troops were going to be fully ready to
defend our interest on the Korean
Peninsula
President Trump says that he may start
easing sanctions on North Korea even
before it ends its entire nuclear
program completely d nuclear Rises
offering this explanation take a look I
think we will do it as fast as it can be
done scientifically as fast as it can be
done mechanically I don't think I mean
I've read horror stories it's a 15 year
process okay if Sumi you wanted to do it
quickly I don't believe that I think
whoever wrote that is wrong but there
will be a point at which when you're 20%
through you can't go back
[Music]
as a member of the Senate Armed Services
Committee can you explain what that
means when you're 20% through you can't
go back well I don't think we should
relax Aang - anyway until we're far down
the path if not at the end of the road
of North Korea's denuclearization I
think the president was just using that
number as an example of the kind of
steps that Kim jong-un needs to pay
he'll have to open his country to
weapons inspectors will need to make a
complete declaration of his nuclear
program then they'll need to develop
steps to remove those nuclear materials
and certify that its denuclearize the
president is right that once you get far
enough down that road it would be very
hard to reverse those steps that we
should not not relax sanctions upfront
Kris in fact that's one reason why
always opposed to deal with Iran because
we were relaxing sanctions we were
giving concessions on the front end for
easily reversed promises as opposed to
getting concrete action from our
adversary and then meant taking action
at the end of that process
in the mean time that the president says
that he is going to maintain his
sanctions regime though he's not going
to call it maximum pressure anymore but
he did say that since the negotiations
have started China has eased up on some
of its tight controls on activity across
the border it seems that South Korea is
anxious to begin trade with North Korea
and the question I have is has by
normalizing things appearing here
meeting with president moon of South
Korea meeting with China has Kim Jang
had already succeeded to some degree in
weakening the maximum pressure campaign
not necessarily by the United States but
by the rest of the world
no Chris I don't think he has China has
always played a double game when it
comes to North Korea on the one hand
saying they want to denuclearize North
Korea but on the other hand propping up
the regime economically financially and
politically they really only came to the
table over the last 18 months because of
the president's approach since last
January the South Korean Administration
that took office earlier this year
simply had a different approach than
previous administrations did the
president has done a good job developing
a rapport with the president moon in
South Korea and trying to keep a close
alliance structure between South Korea
Japan and the United States to ensure
that that pressure campaign continues
and while the president may not want to
say it at the summit I will say it we
need to continue maximum pressure on
North Korea until they be nuclear ice
finally President Trump had a number of
very optimistic things to say about
where things stand now with North Korea
here are a few clips it's a very great
day it's a very great moment in the
history of the world they have I think a
very good relationship with chairman Kim
right now I really do I mean you can't
insure anything all I can say is they
want to make a deal
senator do you share president runs
optimism well we've certainly broken out
of the rut of 0.5 years of failed US
policy towards North Korea I don't know
if Kim jong-un is going to keep his
commitments or not the president
obviously has spent hours with him now
and very few of us have the benefit of
that experience I hope the president is
right but because the Kim regime of Kim
jong-un and his father and his
grandfather have a long history of
duplicity we need to continue our
pressure campaign we need to hold Kim
jong-un to his commitments I think we'll
find out in a matter of months whether
he's willing to keep those commitments
it's under there Tom cotton thank you
for your time today thank you Chris